all right in this video we're going to
be talking about a geometry final exam
review I'm going to be going through the
entire geometry course hitting on some
key questions that you're definitely
going to want to know on your final exam
so first semester second semester I'm
going to try to go sequentially through
the course so if you're just working on
the second half of the course you might
want to skip ahead in this video if you
want to just review some of the earlier
topics we're going to be going through
those in order let's dive in and the
first question is really dealing with
this diagram right here we've got two
planes that are intersecting and it's
asking us can we name three collinear
points so what does that mean collinear
well Co means same and linear means line
so it's three points that lie on the
same line so when we look at this
diagram do you see three points that are
on the same line well we could do point
A D and B that would be one possibility
we could also do points c d and e that
would be another possibility now you
wouldn't want to say something like t d
and U because we don't really know if
they're in a straight line they kind of
look like they might be but we don't
know for sure because there's not really
a line drawn through them and so that's
going to be one example for number one
now you might want to pause the video as
we're going through this and try to do
these problems on your own and then
check them when I do them and so you can
kind of test yourself and see where
you're at
for number two now
it says another name for plane R so what
would be another name for this flat
surface right here this plane r
well if I was going to do this I would
use points a T and B for example
and I would just write it like this
plane
a t
B and the key is you want to pick three
points that are not in a straight line
that lie in the plane and there's more
than one correct answer I mean you could
do Point U A and B and then just write
the word plane in front of it a lot of
different possibilities what you
wouldn't want to do is do points a D and
B for example because plane s and plane
R go through those same three points so
it's not going to be a unique plane
there
for number three now can you name a pair
of opposite rays
now what does that mean opposite rays
well it means that they have the same
endpoint but they're going 180 degrees
opposite so together they form like a
line and so there's a couple different
possibilities here we could do ray DB
and Ray D A the key is when you draw
these Rays is you want to have the ray
going to the right
and you also want the starting point CD
okay is right here and then it's going
in the direction of b or in the
direction of a now sometimes people are
confused because they say well this Ray
is going to the right this Ray is going
to the left but you can see the Arrow
when you write the ray is always drawn
to the right like that
okay and so together you can see that
they're forming a line straight line
okay number four the intersection of
plane R and S so where did plane R and S
intersect or cross well you can see that
they're actually Crossing at this line
here a b and you don't want to make it a
segment you don't want to make it array
you don't want to make it a point you
definitely want to write it as a line
and draw that line symbol above it a b
and the idea is the plane you know it
keeps going and you know like this
direction in this direction and so what
happens is that the intersection of the
line will continue in both directions as
well okay if any of these questions are
just like you know whoa I forgot that
topic you might want to go back and
check out my complete geometry course
I've got 11 lessons breaking down like
chapter by chapter typically like in a
geometry course going into more depth
talking about these Concepts so check
that out on YouTube it's free so you can
resource that now number five if we're
going to do this one Point T is between
s and U find s t t u and S U given this
right here so see if you can do that
problem go ahead and pause the video one
thing that I'll mention is that when you
see St notice there's not a symbol above
it like a line segment or array or a
line that is really saying find the
length of St or the distance between s
and t and then the other important thing
is that when they say t is between s and
U what does that mean betweenness well
you might want to draw a diagram between
means that these three points they lie
on like a line or a line segment so say
for example you have t is between s and
U it's not necessarily the midpoint it's
just in between and so now what we're
given here is the length ST which is
2x minus 1 and T U is X plus 4 and this
whole length s u is 5X minus 3.
okay so the other important concept here
is What's called the segment addition
postulate you probably remember that so
segment addition posture means the two
segments added together equal the whole
segment so what that means is that we
can add these two together and it's
going to equal this whole length so
let's go ahead and do that we've got 2x
minus 1. plus X plus 4 is equal to 5x
minus 3. so we've got some basic algebra
here combining like terms
let's go ahead and subtract 3x from both
sides
and let's go ahead and add 3 to both
so if we do that
we get 6 is equal to 2X and if we divide
both sides by 2 you can see that X is
coming out to 3. but what we need to do
is we really need to find the lengths of
these segments so sometimes when
students do this they do the algebra
they think okay I'm done but you want to
make sure you answer the question and
we're going to put it back in So if we
put in X is equal to 3 that's going to
give us 6 minus 1 so St is equal to 5.
so let's just put that right here for s
t t u is going to be 3 plus 4 which is 7
and then over here Su 5 times 3 is 15.
minus 3 is 12 which makes sense because
5 plus 7 is equal to 12. the two
segments add up to the whole length okay
let's go on to number six see if you can
do this one on your own find the
midpoint and the distance between 1
negative 3 and negative 4 9. so how
would you do that one
now when you're going through this video
here you might want to make a little
note sheet like with important formulas
and Concepts and that kind of thing so
when you're studying so when we talk
about the midpoint the formula that you
want to memorize or know is X1 plus X2
divided by 2 and y1 plus Y2 divided by
2. so when you're finding the midpoint
it's like an average of the x's and an
average of the Y's so let's go ahead and
do that we've got the x coordinates
added together 1 plus negative 4 divided
by 2 and the Y coordinates to get added
together divided by 2.
and that's going to be our midpoint so
this is going to come out to negative 3
halves and negative 3 plus 9 is 6 over 2
which is 3 and that's our midpoint now
if we want to do the distance again you
might want to write this formula down
it's the square root of the difference
in the x coordinates squared plus the
difference in the Y coordinates squared
you add those together and take the
square root and that gives you the
distance or the length between the two
points so if I was going to do this one
here what we're going to do is we're
going to do negative 4 minus 1.
squared nine minus negative 3
squared add those together and take the
square root so we've got negative 5
squared
and this is going to be subtractions
like adding the opposite so that's going
to give us 12 squared add those together
and take the square root so we've got 25
plus 144 which is 169 and what's the
square root of 169 that's going to be 13
so that's going to be our distance okay
let's go on to number seven now see if
you can pause the video and do this one
it says given the midpoint M negative 2
3 and endpoint a47 of segment a b find
the endpoint b x comma Y how would you
do that one well if they don't give you
a diagram sometimes it's helpful just to
draw a diagram it doesn't have to be
perfect but like say for example this is
uh point a which we know is 4 7 and
let's just say here's your midpoint
right in the middle and that's negative
2 3 and we're trying to solve for point
B which we don't know the coordinates
we'll just call that X comma y
so there's two different ways to do this
and it depends on your teacher some
teachers will want you to show the work
but I'm going to show you a shortcut
method after I show you this so see if
you can do this one
we talked about in a previous problem
how to find the midpoint right so you
add the x coordinates and you divide by
two so you'd say X plus 4 divided by 2
equals the x coordinate of the midpoint
same thing with the Y's we could say y
plus seven
divided by 2 is equal to the y
coordinate of the midpoint then all you
have to do is multiply both sides by 2
okay and then over here multiply both
sides by two
and then notice what you have you've
just got X plus 4 is equal to negative 4
and Y plus 7 is equal to 6. if we
subtract 4 from both sides x equals
negative eight if we subtract 7 from
both sides y equals negative one so our
Point here is going to be negative eight
comma negative one now that takes a
little bit of work and on a test I know
sometimes you're pressed for time so
here's the shortcut you say how do I get
from 4 to negative two we'll see how I
subtracted 6. If I subtract 6 again
negative 2 minus 6 gives me negative 8.
pretty neat right same thing here you
can say how am I going from this y
coordinate to this y coordinate 7 minus
4 is 3 If I subtract 4 again 3 minus 4
is negative one so that's a quick way to
do it if you have the end point in the
midpoint and you want to find that other
endpoint
okay now go ahead and pause the video
Try number eight it says classify this
polygon here and determine if it's
concave or convex so how would you do
that one well
first of all is it concave or convex
well concave you can kind of think of it
as like it's like caved in like it's
been pushed in and you can see that's
what's happened here it's like somebody
dented this polygon right
so definitely it's going to be concave
now that's kind of a one way to look at
it another way to look at is if you
extend one of the sides of the polygon
and it goes through the interior of the
polygon then we say it's concave if
every side of the polygon when you
extend it it never goes through the
interior then it's convex I just like to
think of caved in or not caved in now
classifying the polygon that's talking
about the number of sides so you can see
there's
one two three four five six seven sides
what do you call a seven-sided polygon
well that's going to be a heptagon hepta
is seven heptagon and you want to
memorize those names like Forest
quadrilateral five is
and again six is hexagon sevens heptagon
eighths octagon nines nonagon and ten is
decagon after that you could just say
like 11 gone 12 gone 13 gone Etc
okay for number nine how would you do
this one it says write four names for
this angle pictured here
so what do you think how would you do
that what are the four different names
for this angle well if I was going to do
it I would say well you could say angle
three and you want to use that angle
symbol you could do angle x y z
you could do angle z y x just change up
the order
you could also just call it by this
vertex here angle y
there's not any other angles at this
vertex when you're saying well why we
know we're talking about that angle
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 10 and 11. so for number 10
we're given this diagram and it wants us
to find the measure of angle EFG and the
measure of angle gfh so how would you do
that one well if I was going to do it
what I notice is that this is a line
here a straight line so that means that
these two angles form what we call a
linear pair linear means line pair means
two and when they form a line like that
this is like a straight angle and it
means that these two angles add up to
180 degrees this is our angle addition
postulate the two angles add up to the
whole angle so what we're going to do is
we're just going to make a little
algebra equation 7x minus 20 plus 2X
minus 25. is equal to 180 degrees that
straight angle so now a little bit of
algebra will combine like terms
let's add the 45 to both sides
so we get 9 x is equal to
225 and if we divide both sides by 9 you
can see that X is coming out to 25 but
we want to plug that back in so I plug
that back in here 7 times 25 is well
actually let's do this one 2 times 25 is
50. 50 minus 25 is just going to be 25
and that means this angle here has to be
180 minus 25 which is
155 degrees
and you can double check that 7 times 25
is 175 minus 20 is 155 okay so for
number 11 now
we've got this diagram and we have Ray v
z
ax angle uvw
okay find the measure of all the angles
now when you think of a bisector by
means two sect means to intersect or two
to cut in half and so what we're going
to do is we're going to cut this angle
into half which means that these two
angles are going to be equal to each
other sometimes students get a little
bit confused like do I add them up and
set them equal to the whole thing that's
the angle addition postulate or do I set
them equal to each other so you kind of
have to look up for those key terms uh
but in this case we're just going to set
them equal so we have 2 times x is 2x 2
times 6 is 12. so that whole angle is
equal to 9x minus 72.
okay so a little bit of algebra here
we're going to subtract 2x from both
sides
and we're going to add 72 to both sides
and if we do that we get 7x is equal to
84 divide both sides by 7 x is equal to
12. now we want to put that back in So
if we put 12 in here 12 plus 6 is 18 2
times 18 is
36 so this angle right here uvz is 36
degrees
and if we put 12 back in here 12 minus 8
is 4 4 times 9 is 36 degrees
and if we add these together you can see
this whole angle here is going to be 36
plus 36 which is 72 degrees that's angle
uvw
okay so if you're still with me see if
you can pause the video and do number 12
and number 13. let's find X and Y in
this diagram here so you can see we've
got two intersecting lines and how can
we solve for x and y
well this problem really speaks to a
couple things one is when you have two
intersecting lines what do you know
about the angles that are across from
each other those are called the vertical
angles and they're congruent and what do
you know about the two angles that form
a line we talked about that in a
previous problem those are a linear pair
those add up to 180 degrees so those are
a couple of hints now if I was going to
do this problem I would probably take
these two angles right here I wouldn't
want to take these for example or the
vertical angles because I've got two
variables and in only one equation so
let's go ahead and use these two here
and I'm just going to set those equal to
180 so I'm going to add them up 7x minus
40. plus 3x plus 20 is equal to 180.
combine like terms so 10x minus 20.
equals 180 add 20 to both sides so 10x
is equal to 200 and divide both sides by
10 x is equal to 20 okay now I can take
this 20 and put it back in say for
example right here 3 times 20 is 60 plus
20 is 80 degrees and now I can use my
vertical angles these angles that are
across from each other are equal to each
other so I can say is let's put it up
here 3y minus 10 is equal to 80. add 10
to both sides
3y is equal to 90 and divide both sides
by 3 and Y is coming out to 30. so we
have y is 30 x is 20 and you got it now
for number 13
how would you do this one a little word
problem the measure of an angle is 3
less than twice the measure of its
complement find both angles so what does
this mean complement
complement means that the two angles
they say nice things to each other no I
mean complement means that they add up
to 90 degrees right so
what we can do is we can draw a diagram
so
complementary again like I said they add
up to 90 which means that they could
form a right angle they don't have to
they don't have to be adjacent angles
that form a right angle but they do add
up to 90. so for example
if I know this angle here let's just say
is X degrees this angle has to be
three less
than twice the complement so three less
than 2x so double this angle three less
than that these two angles together have
to add up to
90 degrees so complementary adds up to
90. supplementary or supplement those
add up to 180. so let's combine like
terms 3x minus 3 equals 90. if we add 3
to both sides
we get 3x is equal to 93 and if we
divide both sides by 3
you can see that X is coming out to 31
so that means that this angle here is 31
degrees this angle must be 2 times 31
which is 62 minus 3 which is 59 degrees
and you can see 59 and 31 add up to 90
degrees so they're complements okay see
if you can do this one we've got if an
angle measures less than 90 degrees then
it is acute so we want to write the
converse the inverse and the
contrapositive so how would you do that
problem see if you can do that one on
your own and the other thing we want to
talk about too is what is the hypothesis
and what is the conclusion so can you
underline the hypothesis and circle the
conclusion try that one so if I was
going to do this one
I would look at this if and then so
conditional statement is like an if then
statement if the hypothesis
okay occurs
then the conclusion okay so that's the
idea hypothesis if the hypothesis then
the conclusion so when you do the
converse what you're doing is you're
like saying it in reverse you're
switching the hypothesis and the
conclusion so we're going to say if
an angle is acute
then
it measures less than 90.
now you might have to finesse the
language a little bit so that it kind of
reads a little bit nice nicer
because sometimes it won't really like
make sense if you just directly switch
them
but the idea here is let's kind of make
a note here so we've got our conditional
statement which is like this if P then Q
our Converse we're saying if Q then P
okay so now the inverse what is the
inverse well the inverse
we're going to keep them in the same
order the hypothesis and the conclusion
what we're going to do is we're going to
negate them so see this little symbol
here in front that means if not P then
not Q so that's the inverse you're
negating them so we're going to say if
an angle does not
does not
measure
less
then
90 degrees then
it is not
cute
okay now here let's make a little uh
Point here sometimes students will say
like
okay if an angle does not measure less
than 90 then it's not acute they might
say something different like if an angle
measures a hundred or they might say an
angle measures
equal to 90 or something like that and
what I'm trying to basically emphasize
that if you just put in the word uh not
that'll take care of everything you know
besides what we're talking about so
instead of saying like then there's not
accuse like saying it's a a obtuse right
see what it could be a right angle right
so that's why if we just say add that
word and not that'll make it the
negation okay so I hope I'm making that
clear so just put the word not in there
to negate it and then the last one the
contrapositive what you're doing is
you're it's kind of a combination of the
converse and the inverse so what you're
doing is you're switching the hypothesis
in the conclusion and you're negating
both of them so what that would be for
this one we would say
if an angle is not acute if an angle
is not acute
not acute
then
uh
it does not measure less than 90. it
does not
measure
less
than
90 degrees okay now another important
point that you might want to make note
of besides the conditional Converse
inverse and contrapositive is that the
conditional statement
and the contrapositive they're what we
call equivalent statements meaning they
have the same truth value if this one is
true this one will be true if this one's
false this will be false and it's the
same thing for the
Converse and the inverse those are
equivalent statements that the converse
is true the inverse is true if the
converse is false the inverse will be
false so sometimes you can use one if
you're a little bit more confident about
the one being true then you say I'm not
sure about this one well it must be true
as well because there are equivalent
statements so
important to know our conditional
Converse inverse contrapositive are
different if then type statements okay
let's dive into number 15 and number 16.
so for number 15 it says write the two
statements as a biconditional statement
okay so here's the two statements if a
point bisects a segment then it is a
midpoint
if a point is a midpoint then it bisects
a segment how do we write that as a
biconditional statement now my
conditional by means two conditional
means if then so it's an if then
statement that's true forward like the
conditional and it's true in Reverse
like the converse is true as well so
let's analyze these statements real
quick if a point bisects the segment
does that mean it's a midpoint yes
that's true and if a point is a midpoint
does that mean that it bisects a segment
yes that's true so you can see how the
conditional and the converse both are
true how do we write it as a
biconditional statement which indicates
that it's true in both directions the
conditional and the converse
all you have to do for this problem is
you drop the if
and you replace the then with this
phrase if and only
if so you can say a point is a midpoint
if and only if it bisects a segment you
could also do that with this first
statement you could drop this if
and replace this then with if and only
if so we could say a point bisex
assignment if and only if it is a
midpoint either of those ones would be
correct but you definitely want to drop
the if and replace it then with if and
only if you also want to make sure that
the conditional is true and that
Converse is true in order to write the
biconditional otherwise it's not
possible to write that by conditional
statement
okay for number 16 now
the instructions on here let me just
read them to you so we want to find out
if this third statement follows from
these first two statements so let's
assume that these first two statements
are true can we make this conclusion
okay this third statement can we
conclude this and is it the Law of
Detachment or the law of syllogism so
we're getting into the laws of logic so
let's read it together if it snows more
than a foot then school will be closed
let's assume that that's a true
statement okay school was closed Monday
let's assume that's a true statement can
we assume or conclude I should say that
it snowed more than a foot
what do you think on that one well
let's analyze law of attachment law of
syllogism and we're going to do another
example number 17 as well so law of
attachment goes like this if P then Q is
true
and P happens what can you conclude
therefore Q must happen right
so let's look what happens here so if it
snows more than a foot school be closed
Monday
school was closed closed or closed
Monday right now notice what's happening
is they're telling us about the
conclusion q and we're making
a statement about the hypothesis see how
we're going in the opposite direction
we're going against that Arrow that's
what we call the converse error or we
can just say it's an invalid argument we
don't know that it snowed more than a
foot school could be closed Monday
because it's a holiday it's summer
vacation uh you know some type of a
special event etc etc so
if they said
it snowed three feet right then we could
say oh yeah definitely school would be
closed okay we could we could because
they're basically saying that the
hypothesis is satisfied so this
conclusion will naturally result okay
but what's Happening Here is they're
saying that oh the conclusion happened
was it caused by this no that's saying
it backward invalid argument the law of
syllogism if you want to write this down
again you might want to add these to
your note sheet goes like this if P then
Q is true
and if Q then R is true if P happens
what can we conclude therefore R will
happen it's kind of like a domino effect
like if P causes q and then Q causes R
if P happens it starts that chain of
events that domino effect and then if P
happens therefore we know R will happen
it's kind of like the transitive
property but we call it the law of
syllogism when it's dealing with these
conditional statements these if then
statements but you want where one ends
the conclusion to be the hypothesis of
the next statement so that's where that
begins and then it creates that chain or
that link or that domino effect let's
take a look at another example let me
read you the instructions for number 17.
so for number 17 let's assume that these
three statements a B and C are all true
what conclusion can you make if any and
what law did you use is use the Law of
Detachment the law of syllogism which
law of logic did you use so let's read
them together
if you wake up late then you'll miss the
bus let's assume that's true and if you
miss the boss then you'll be tardy for
your first hour let's assume that's true
Joe woke up late let's assume that's
true what kind of a conclusion can you
make if any
well sometimes when I'm doing problems
like this I like to diagram it out so I
might do something like this
if you wake up late
so let's just write wake late wake late
then you miss bus right now if you miss
the bus so let's write that one out Miss
bus
then
you're tardy for first hour okay Joe
woke up late so what can we conclude
well notice that waking up late means
you missed the bus then missing the boss
means that you're tardy so waking up
late through that chain of events that
law of syllogism means that you're going
to be tardy Joe woke up late that
triggers this first hypothesis here
which caused that chain event so we
could say that Joe is going to be tardy
for his first hour right now if they
said that Joe was tardy could we say
that was because he woke up late no that
would be an invalid argument in that
case because they're going against the
direction of the arrow okay basically he
could be tardy for a number of reasons
maybe the boss broke down or maybe he
was sick that day or maybe some other
event you know happened but because Joe
was waking up late and this conclusion
is this hypothesis in the next statement
which leads to this conclusion we have
that law of syllogism at play and uh we
can make a valid argument that Joe is
going to be tardy for his first hour
okay let's look at number 18. see if you
can do these two you want to name the
property that's being Illustrated here
so for letter A if the measure of angle
x equals measure of angle Y and measure
of angle y equals the measure of angle Z
then the measure of angle x equals the
measure of angle Z so what's the
property Illustrated there
well notice that this is kind of sounds
like our law of syllogism right we have
x equals Y and Y equals z so the first
is equal to the last right it's kind of
through that change this angle Y is
acting like a connector here
so this is actually called the
transitive property transitive property
okay and then for letter B here if the
measure of angle three equals measure
angle four then why would the measure
angle four equal to measure angle three
kind of sounds like the same thing
doesn't it but what we did was we
switched the order of three equals four
four equals three what property is that
is the symmetric property
and there's another property that I
didn't do a problem about and that's the
reflexive property anything is equal to
itself it's kind of like a reflection
like you're the same height in the
mirror as you are in real life like
angle a is equal to angle a anything is
equal to itself that's called reflexive
so we've got transitive symmetric
reflexive those are important to know
okay for number 19 what we're going to
do is we're going to do an algebra
two column proof so what you're going to
do is you're going to solve this
equation but I want you to justify each
step if you would please
and for number 20 we're going to
identify a line that's skew two line b e
and this rectangular prism so go ahead
and pause the video see if you can do
both of these problems
now if I was going to do number 19 what
I would do here is I would probably draw
a line like I'm doing a two column proof
and this first statement here is our
given so I'm just going to say given
now the next step is going to be 2x
minus 8 is equal to 5x plus 9. so what
did I do to get from here to here I just
multiplied that 2 into the parentheses
that's what we call the distributive
property
okay so it's just like solving the
algebra equation you did you know in a
previous course but we were justifying
each step so just kind of getting into
the the two column proofs so the next
step I would say is negative 3x minus 8
is equal to 9. so what did I do to get
from here to here I subtracted 5x from
both sides of the equation that keeps it
balanced that's what we call the
subtraction property
of equality so I'm just abbreviating a
little bit but you can write that out
subtraction property of equality
because you're doing it to both sides
keeping it equal The Next Step I would
have negative 3x is equal to 17 and what
did I do there I added uh 8 to both
sides so we could say that's the
addition property of equality and then
the last step here we have X is equal to
negative 17 thirds and what did I do
there I divided both sides by negative 3
that's called our division
property of equality and you solve the
equation and you Justified all the steps
so number 20 now we've got this
rectangular prism and we're talking
about what's a line that's skew to be
now what does that mean skew
well we know what parallel means that
parallel means that two lines they don't
intersect but they're in the same plane
the same flat surface so we wouldn't
want to say like CF that's actually
parallel to be right we wouldn't want to
say f e and b e those look like they're
perpendicular to each other and they're
in the same plane what we could do is we
could say like GF and b e so for example
a line GF would be skew so skew is kind
of like let's see if I can do this like
this and like this right okay so
basically they're not intersecting but
they're in two different planes two
different flat surfaces you could also
do DC would be another possibility
what's another one here you could do d a
would be another possibility so there's
you know more than one here but
basically you want to make sure they're
not in the same plane like for example
DG would actually be parallel to be okay
so good job on that one okay for number
21 see if you can do this problem on
your own we want to classify the pair of
angles as vertical angles linear pair
corresponding angles alternate interior
alternate exterior consecutive interior
or none
and we're going to do a through G here
so see if you can pause the video and do
these on your own it's in this diagram
right here so let's dive in so for
letter a angle 4 and angle 14 so we have
four and 14. now what's the connection
between those two angles now you
probably remember when you were learning
about this in your geometry course
earlier you you had like parallel lines
cut by a transversal and you know you
have like these eight angles here like
one two three four five six seven eight
now the diagram we have here is a little
bit different because you've got four
lines right and they're not parallel
lines right so you kind of have to block
out some of the lines that you're not
using so what I mean by that is when we
look at angle 4 and 14. see how 4 and 14
they both have this transversal they
have this in common and we can kind of
block out this part of the diagram here
and we can see that okay this is on the
left side this is on the right side and
they're outside okay they're on the
exterior interior would be in between
the lines so 4 and 14 would be what we
call alternate exterior angles
so let's see if we can just draw an
arrow here alternate exterior angles
okay for letter B now angle eight and
angle 10 what'd you get for that one so
eight and ten notice how angle eight
angle 10 both touch this line here this
is your transversal and notice that 8
and 10 are in between these two lines so
these are going to be alternate interior
angles and that's going to be let's see
right here
okay for letter c angle 1 and angle 7.
okay what do you notice about these two
angles here well notice whenever you
have two lines that intersect they form
kind of like an X shape like that the
angles that are across from each other
we call these vertical angles so that's
going to be right here vertical
and then for letter D 13 and 14. what do
we know about these two angles well you
can see that these are forming a line
this is what we call a linear pair they
form a line so that's going to be this
one right here angle six and angle seven
what do we know about these two angles
now these two angles notice how angle
six touches this line and angle seven
touches that line that's our transversal
and notice that six and seven are in
between these two lines so you could
kind of block out this part of your
diagram you might rotate this a little
bit
you can see that these are on the same
side of that transversal and they're
inside so this is consecutive interior
angles consecutive interior which is
this one right here
and then 12 and 10
so we've got 12 here we've got 10 here
you can see 12 and 10 both touch this
line here this is our transversal and
you might block out this part of the
diagram up here even rotate this or turn
your head a little bit you can see that
12 is like in the upper right hand
corner and 10 is like in the upper right
hand corner if I take this x here this X
and slide it down over here see how 12
and 10 like match up with one another
those are what we call corresponding
angles it would be like 2 and 6 in this
diagram or one and five see upper left
upper left or lower right lower right
they correspond
so that's 12 and 10 so we said
corresponding okay and then for letter G
angle 2 and angle 14
okay now notice angle 14 it touches this
line and this line right and notice
angle 2 touches this line and this line
there's no line that connects these two
together that they have in common
there's no transversal there's really no
connection between angle 2 and angle 14.
so this one we're going to say is none
and you got it okay so see if you can
pause the video and do number 22 and 23.
these ones what I like for you to do if
you would is solve for x okay and one
thing to note about these two problems
is that see these arrows here what does
that tell us about the lines it tells us
that they're parallel right so that is a
little bit of a clue so go ahead and try
22 and 23 if I was going to do it I
would look at these two angles and say
what are those angles and how are they
related well I can see that they're
interior they're in between the two
parallel lines one's on the left one's
on the right we call these alternate
interior angles and unlike the previous
problem where the lines weren't parallel
when they're parallel like this the
alternative angles are congruent which
means that they're equal so 5x is equal
to 125 if we divide both sides by 5 x is
going to equal 25.
okay degrees okay for 23
when I look at these two angles I can
see that they're on the same side of the
transversal and they're interior we call
these consecutive interior angles or
some books call it a same side interior
angles what do I know about these when
the lines are parallel I know that those
two angles are supplementary which means
that they add up to
180 degrees so I can make a little
equation here
and solve so let's see this comes out to
2x plus a hundred
and I can subtract 100 from both sides
just doing a little bit of algebra here
2X equals 80 divide both sides by 2 and
we can see that X is equal to 40. okay
good and then for number 24 we're given
these three lines l m and n and we have
this transversal and it's asking us is
line L this Top Line parallel to line
and this bottom line and how do you know
so that's an interesting question now we
don't have any arrows like these ones
where we would know that the lines are
parallel like it's given here we're
actually trying to prove that the lines
are parallel and it looks like these two
angles are congruent they've got the
same markings they both have those two
little arcs on there
well if I was going to do this problem I
would say that yes indeed L and N are
parallel because these are what we call
alternate exterior angles and if the
alternate exterior angles are congruent
by the alternate exterior angle Converse
that proves that the two lines are
parallel now this line M I kind of threw
that in there just to throw you off a
little bit you kind of cover that up or
erase it but basically the alternate
exterior angles are congruent the two
lines are parallel by the converse so
whenever you prove lines parallel you
can use your corresponding angles
theorem your alternator angle's theorem
all those theorems that we've been using
but when you use it to prove lines
parallel and you're working backwards
like that you want to add that word
converse to it
okay so for number 25
find the line that's parallel to this
line and it goes through this point now
of course there's a lot of lines that
are parallel to this line but we're
finding the particular one that goes to
this point how would you do that one see
if you can pause the video and do that
now if I was going to do it the first
thing I would do is I would rearrange
this equation into what we call the
slope intercept form what's the slope
intercept form it's that y equals MX
plus b form of the equation of a line
where we solve for one y so I'm going to
divide everything by negative three
and that's going to give us y equals
positive two-thirds x minus two so this
is our slope intercept form remember the
number that comes in front of the ax
that's our Amer slope and this B value
that's our constant that's our
y-intercept and that's our slope
intercept form so now we know the slope
is two-thirds if lines are parallel that
means they're going up at the same rate
right the same angle they have the same
slope
and if we have a point what we might
want to do is use the point-slope form
of the equation of a line so you might
want to write these formulas down add
them to your note sheet if you're kind
of keeping track of all these important
Concepts and the point that the line
goes through is this X1 y1 this is our
X1 y1 so this is going to be y minus 2
equals our slope remember the same as
the slope is the original line and x
minus negative 1. of course when you
subtract it's like adding the opposite
now what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to distribute and just kind of
rewrite this equation a little bit so 2
3 X Plus two-thirds
y minus 2 let's go ahead and add 2 to
both sides of course 2 is like 2 over 1
I'm going to get common denominators by
multiplying by three over three and so
that comes out to 2 3 x this is six
thirds plus two-thirds which is eight
thirds
and that's it that's the equation of our
line parallel to the given line through
the given point okay if you're enjoying
this review so far and you want more
practice once you're done with this
check out my geometry midterm review and
my final exam my geometry final exam
review that I did a few years back you
can check those out this one I did kind
of all together the whole year the whole
first semester and second semester but I
broke it down into two videos in a few
years back you might want to check those
out but for 26 try this problem it says
find the equation of the perpendicular
bisector of segment x y and you've got
point x and you've got point Y now what
does that mean a perpendicular bisector
well if you have a segment to bisect
means you to cut it in half so basically
you're you're finding the midpoint
you're going right through the middle
cutting it in half and you're at a right
angle so that's a little bit of a clue
now in order to find the midpoint we did
this in an earlier problem in this video
You Average the x's and you average the
Y so what you would do is you would say
negative six plus two
divided by 2 and 3 plus negative 9.
divided by 2. so if we do that we get
negative 4 over 2 which is negative 2
and negative 6 over 2 which is negative
3. so that's our midpoint now the next
thing we want to do is we want to find
the slope okay so the slope of the
original line segment x y and to do that
we use our formula Y2 minus y1 over X2
minus X1 so negative 9 minus
negative a negative 9 minus 3
and 2 minus negative 6. so if we
simplify we get negative 12
over 8 which is negative three halves
but when you find the perpendicular that
means you're going to have to take the
opposite reciprocal slope so he changes
from negative to positive and the
reciprocal means we flip it over so now
we have the perpendicular slope we have
the midpoint which is what the line goes
through the perpendicular bisector we
can write an equation in
point-slope form so we're going to do y
minus our y coordinate so y minus
negative 3 is like y plus 3. we have our
slope which is two-thirds x minus our x
coordinate which would be x minus
negative 2 which is like X Plus 2. now
this is point-slope form you could
distribute the two thirds and subtract
the three and rewrite it in slope
intercept form if you like but for now
let's just I'll leave it like that
now for 27 we've got a part A and Part B
we're given these two segments and it
says name the vector that translates
segment a b to segment a prime B Prime
in component form and then write a rule
for the translation okay so how would
you do that one see if you can pause the
video if I was going to do it I would be
looking at how am I going from a to a
prime well it looks like I'm going right
one
and down four so that means this is
going to be 1 comma negative 4 and
notice we use the Triangular brackets
for a vector in component form as
opposed to parentheses for like a
coordinate and this tells us the
horizontal direction we're going right
one the minus 4 tells us we're going
down 4 and that's how I'm getting from a
to a prime that's like our Vector that's
sliding this segment
the other way to do this uh problem is
you can take the terminal minus initial
you take the ending point minus the
starting point so 1 minus 0 gives us 1
and negative 2 minus 2 gives us negative
4. that's another way to do it
for Part B though writing a rule what I
would do is I would say t for
translation of the point x y maps to X
Plus 1 y minus 4. so what that means is
you're taking the x coordinate you're
adding 1 which shifts it right one and
you're taking the y coordinate you're
subtracting 4 which shifts it down four
Let's test that out with the point B
three plus one is four okay good and 1
minus 4 is negative three see how it
matches so this is a rule and this is a
vector
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 28 and 29 on your own we've
got reflect triangle DEF that's this
triangle over here over the line Y
equals negative X and we've got the
point zero two two four one zero so what
would be the new coordinates of D Prime
e Prime F Prime and I wrote down some of
the rules here you might want to add
these to your formula sheet if you need
to memorize these for your test
x-axis this is the rule for reflecting
over the x y y equals x and y equals
negative X which is what we're doing in
this problem so how would you do that
one well if I was going to do it the
line Y equals negative X is a why not a
diagonal with a negative one slope so it
goes through the origin and it has a
negative one slope kind of like that now
if you have graph paper what you can do
is you can measure the perpendicular
distance to that line of reflection and
you go the same distance on the other
side at a right angle so you just
measure the distance same distance on
the other side you can count the squares
on the diagonal that's one way to do it
it's a quick way or you can use this
rule y equals negative X so what we're
doing is we're switching the X and Y
coordinates okay and we're making the
opposite sign so what I mean by that is
we're going to switch these two and zero
but I'm going to make the X and Y the
opposite of course the opposite of 0 is
still zero so negative 2 0 would put us
right here that's our D Prime e Prime
we're going to switch them and negate
them or make them the opposite I should
say so that's going to be negative 4
negative 2 that's going to put us down
right here so this is a d Prime e Prime
and then F we're going to switch them
and make them the opposite so negative 0
is still 0 negative one that's going to
put us right here F Prime if we connect
those up
you can see it's like folding it over
that line now just a quick review so
with the x-axis when you reflect you
make the y coordinate the opposite sign
when you reflect over the y-axis you
make the x coordinate the opposite sign
when you reflect over the line Y equals
X you actually just interchange the X
and the Y and the line Y equals negative
X you interchange the X and the Y and
you make them the opposite signs
so for number 29 now we're getting into
rotations
how would you do this one you want to
rotate this segment X Y 90 degrees
counterclockwise that's this direction
about the origin now if the point x is 2
3 and the point Y is 4 negative 1 I've
drawn that for us here what would be the
new coordinates of X Prime y Prime now
you might want to add these uh to your
formula sheet if you're memorizing the
rotations X Y what you do is you switch
the X and the Y and you make this new x
coordinate the opposite okay the 180 you
keep them in the same order but you make
them the opposite signs and for 270 you
switch them and you make this one the
new one here the opposite the new y
coordinate is how I like to say it but
you can think of X Y becomes negative YX
negative x negative y y Negative X okay
so let's do this one how would you do it
if I was going to do it I would look at
my rotation for 90 degrees I'm going to
switch the order here so this is going
to be 3 and 2 I'm going to make the new
x coordinate the opposite same thing
here I'm going to switch the order
negative 1 4 I'm going to make the new x
coordinate the opposite so that becomes
a positive one so if I plot these points
negative 3 2 is going to put us right
here that's X Prime and 1 4 is going to
put us right here that's y Prime let's
go ahead and connect those and if you
can kind of visualize if I was to hold
my finger at this point and turn the
paper 90 degrees a quarter turn you can
see that there would be a 90 degree
rotation so great job if you're able to
get that one okay so continuing on
number 30 it says draw the lines of
reflection and identify any rotational
symmetry and you can see we're given a
hexagon here it looks like a regular
hexagon so when we look at the lines of
reflection how many lines can we draw we
could draw one here
one here
one here and we can also go through the
vertices like that
like that and like that so it looks like
we have six lines of symmetry that we
can fold over and have it matched to
itself now when we do the rotational
symmetry we're asking us how many
degrees can we rotate this so that it
matches to itself and when we do this we
measure all the angles up to 180 but not
exceeding so in this case if we think of
this as kind of like a knob we're
turning
it looks like we could rotate this
60 120 or 180 degrees now how am I
getting those numbers well when it's a
regular figure like this a regular
polygon if you take like the number of
lines of symmetry which there were six
lines of symmetry and if you take 360
Degrees divided by six you get that
fundamental angle of rotation at 60
degrees and you can do multiples of that
up to and including 180. so that's how
I'm doing that if it's a regular figure
like that 360 divided by 6 is 60 and
then it multiples of that up to 180.
okay so for number 31 now it says find
the angle of rotation from X to X double
Prime so you can see what we're doing
here is we're reflecting this original
figure over line C then we're reflecting
it over line D and we want to know how
many degrees is it rotating from here to
here so from this figure to the final
figure
well when you do a double reflection
like this so when you first reflect it
it's like in a different orientation but
then when you reflect it again now it's
in the original orientation it's just a
rotation how many degrees do you think
that would be 30 no it's actually double
that angle between the two intersecting
lines so this would rotate 60 degrees so
that's the key for that one now if there
were parallel lines and you may have a
question like this when you reflect over
a parallel lines okay what happens is it
ends up being a translation or a slide
double the distance between the parallel
lines so you might see a problem like
that on your test for 32 it says what is
the scale factor from
I should have said let's say this is our
Center here from CF to c f Prime so this
is your center of dilation like you're
expanding out from here to go from CF to
c f Prime okay well what do you think on
that one and then also find out the
length of this new side of the triangle
right here x how would you do that one
well the important thing to remember
about scale factor in dilations is this
little formula that I like to think of I
like to think of the new
over the old that's just a kind of a
quick way of doing it so I'm saying the
new length is from C to F Prime which
you can see that's a length of six
and the old one was from C to F that was
two and if I divide 6 divided by 2
that's a scale factor of three it's like
dilating by three times so if that's the
case if this side here is 5 5 times 3
would give us a length of 15 for x
so that's the key new over old for scale
factor now for 33 how would you classify
this triangle by its side lengths and by
its angles so what do you think for that
one
well you can see that two of the sides
are congruent that makes it an isosceles
triangle and you can see one of the
angles is greater than 90 that's obtuse
so I would say for this one
obtuse isosceles
triangle
and you got it okay see if you can pause
the video and do number 34 35 and 36
here we're solving for all the missing
angles one two three four five here
we're solving for x and here we're
solving for y so go ahead and try those
and uh if I was going to do this one
here I would look for clues or hints in
the diagram so one clue would be that
these lines are parallel
and you can see we were given some
angles here as well so let's see so I
can see if I have parallel lines cut by
a transversal that means that these
angles here are alternate interior
angles and that means they're going to
be equal so that means angle 3 is going
to be 40 degrees
now over here this is 110 and these form
a linear pair which means that they add
up to 180 so that means that angle 1 is
going to be 70 degrees
and then one and five are alternate
interior angles okay so that means angle
5 is 70.
and then we can see that these three
formal lines so they should add up to
180 so that's 110 so angle 2 must also
be 70. you can also do that these angles
have to add up to 180 because they form
a triangle and all the angles in a
triangle app to 180 and then these ones
are vertical angles so angle four would
be 70 degrees or you could see that
these form a linear pair and they add up
to 180. so a few different ways to
navigate that problem
now for number 35 how would you solve
for x what did you get for that one
well one thing to notice is that all
three of these sides are the same in
this triangle so that means it's an
equilateral triangle equilateral
triangles are also equiangular which
means all the angles are equal which
means that this has to be a 60 degree
angle 60 60 60 adds up to 180.
and then for 36 we can see that this is
an isosceles triangle what do we know
about isosceles triangles well we know
that the base angles are congruent so
this angle and this angle are congruent
so what we could do is we could say well
if this angle is 30 these two angles
have to add up to 150 because all the
angles in a triangle have to 180 but if
these are congruent to each other that
means each of these has to be 75 degrees
half of 150. so all we have to do is say
2y minus 1 is equal to 75 add 1 to both
sides so 2y is equal to 76 and then
divide both sides by 2 and you can see
that Y is coming out to 38 and you got
it
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 37 part A and B it says can
you prove the two triangles are
congruent and how
okay so let's look at letter A so what
do you think how would you prove these
two triangles congruent well if I was
going to do it what I would notice is
that we've got these parallel lines
which means that this angle and this
angle are congruent by alternate
interior angles
and we also know that these angles are
congruent by vertical angles and they
gave us that these two segments are
congruent so it looks like we have angle
side angle angle side angle so that's
how I would prove these two triangles
congruent by the angle side angle
triangle congruence theorem and remember
there's five different ways to prove
triangles congruent you've got the angle
side angle you've got side side side you
have side angle side you have angle
angle side and you have a hypotenuse leg
if it's a right triangle you can use
that with hypotenuse leg theorem so for
letter B what do you think for this one
we've got two overlapping triangles
sometimes it helps to draw them
separately kind of pull them apart but
it looks like they're telling us that
this length here our U is congruent
through this length here
TS we both have right angles
and what's interesting when you have
overlapping triangles is that you have
to remember that they share this side
right here so if I was to draw these a
little bit
kind of smaller like this it basically
would look something like this so you
have
two right angles these hypotenuses are
congruent and look this leg is congruent
so what we have is hypotenuse leg okay
so we have a right triangles the
hypotenuse circle group one of the legs
are congruent now we should also talk
about and you want to review this is how
do you write the triangle congruence
statement so for this top one you'd have
triangle
ACB triangle ACB is congruent to
Triangle
dce and remember the order is important
because you want to match up the
corresponding angles and the
corresponding sides so the way that I
sometimes do it if I'm doing a c b see I
have one mark two marks no marks on the
angles I can follow that same pattern
one mark two Mark no marks and that way
I can line up the corresponding vertices
okay the corresponding angles and the
corresponding sides same thing over here
I could do like um let's see if I'm
doing hypotenuse like I could do the
hypotenuse the leg is congruent and then
the other leg so hypotenuse leg like
that so if I was to do that that would
be let's see it would be s t r
iangle Str is congruent to Triangle
let's see that would be
um let's see Str so we're going to do
this hypotenuse we're going to use u r t
so triangle u r t and there's more than
one way to do it you can write them in
different orders as long as the
corresponding parts match up is the key
so for 38 now how can we describe how to
prove that this angle 1 is congruent to
angle two
what would you do for that one go ahead
and pause the video see if you can try
that one
one thing that you'll notice is that
these two triangles they share this side
in common so that's by the reflexive
property and so then what we can do is
we can prove that these two triangles
are congruent by the side side triangle
congruence theorem then you can see that
if I rotate and match up the
corresponding parts we can say that
angle one is congruent to angle two by
the cpctc the corresponding parts of
congruent triangles are congruent But
first you want to prove the triangles
are congruent using that side side side
congruence
for number 39 now this is more like a
coordinate proof it says find the
coordinates of Point J that's this point
here J and I should have stated for the
parallelogram
h i j k h i j k so this is a
parallelogram how do you find this
missing Point here
go ahead and see if you can do that one
now notice they're giving us
some of the vertices here and they're
doing it in terms of a variable or a
letter and not a number so
well it looks like when you think of a
parallelogram see this height here see
I'm going right a up B
so over here this height here should be
B so this y coordinate the height should
be the same as the height for the y
coordinate for point I
now let's see to get over here we're
going let's see this length here must be
C see how this is c0 so if this length
here is C this length here must also be
C because in a parallelogram the
opposite sides are congruent so if I'm
going right A C to get to here plus
another C that means that this point
must be a plus c
comma B A plus C comma B okay great job
if you're able to get that one okay
let's see if you can do number 40 now
we've got we're solving for x here and
notice what we have we've got an angle
angle GFE and then we have this angle
bisector array f h so how can we solve
for x in this problem well if I was
going to do this problem what I would
notice is that when you have a point on
your angle bisector and you measure that
perpendicular distance to either side of
the angle those two distances are going
to be congruent so that's the theorem
with the angle bisector and so what you
want to do is you want to set these
equals so 2x plus 4
is equal to 3x plus 2. let's see we'll
subtract 2x from both sides and we'll
subtract 2 from both sides so that comes
out to X is equal to two and you got it
now you can also prove this by see how
this
segment right here this hypotenuse of
this triangle is congruent in both of
these triangles so what we have is angle
angle side angle angle side the two
triangles are congruent so by the cpctc
the corresponding parts of congruent
triangles these two segments would be
equal
okay so for number 41 what do you think
you would do on this one
well we've got a lot of lines going on
in this diagram so let me see if I can
kind of explain a little bit so what
type of
um
line is this right here well notice it's
perpendicular to this side of the
triangle and it's cutting it in half
it's bisecting it so it's a
perpendicular bisector and notice what
we have here we also have a
perpendicular bisector and on this side
we also have a perpendicular bisector
so where do all those perpendicular
bisectors coincide or what's that point
of concurrency as they say well this
point of concurrency is called the
circumcenter and the reason they call
the circumcenter is because you can
circumscribe or draw a circle
around the triangle okay roughly like
that and that's a hint so what do you
know about the length of Y right here
this distance from this circumcenter
point to this point on the triangle the
vertex well if I was going to do this I
would notice that this is a radius of
the circle and see how 9 is also a
radius of the circle so we don't want
eight we don't want six we don't want
seven we want the distance from the
center to each vertex and I could have
also drawn a line like this to this
point these are all radii they're all
going to be congruent and you just want
to remember again that the three
perpendicular bisectors coincide at the
circumcenter and the three angle
bisectors coincide at the in center and
the three altitudes coincide at the
orthocenter and
the three medians coincide at the
centroid so we'll talk about some of
those problems as we go through so
number 42 now
it looks like we've got the angle
bisectors see how this angle is being
bisected this angle is being bisected
and again this point where they're
intersecting we call this point the
insetter so what is the length of X
right here from this in Center to point
e see if you can do that one see if you
remember how that works now if I was
going to do it
what I know about the in Center is that
you can inscribe or draw a circle on the
inside of the triangle such that it just
barely touches the sides of the triangle
so that when you draw a radius to that
point of tangency those are all going to
be congruent because they're all the
radii of a circle so if you look at this
triangle right here I can see that this
is an 8 15 17 Pythagorean triple you
could also do the Pythagorean theorem
you know a squared plus b squared equals
c squared to solve for this side eight
once I know that radius 8 I know that
this radius is going to be 8 and I also
know that X is going to be equal to 8.
so all those radii are congruent so on
your note sheet you might want to make a
note of
you know the in Center is where the
three angle bisectors cross and you
inscribe a circle that kind of helps
three perpendicular bisectors that's
where you circumscribe a circle and
again you can look at the three radii
there okay so for number 43 how do you
find the centroid of triangle ABC when
you're just given the three vertices of
that triangle how would you do that one
well if I was going to do it I would use
the centroid formula and the centroid
formula basically what you're doing is
you're averaging the x coordinates so
you're adding them all divided and
dividing them by three and you're adding
all the Y coordinates we're together and
dividing by three so that's how you find
the centroid it's like the center of
gravity the center of mass it's kind of
like a balance point basically for that
triangle if you're going to balance it
so if we do this we've got negative one
plus two plus negative four so let's see
that comes out to negative three
divided by 3 and we've got six plus
three is nine plus zero is nine so nine
divided by three so this is coming out
to negative one comma three that's going
to be your centroid see if you can pause
the video and do number 44 so what do we
have here we've got a triangle and it
looks like we're drawing from the vertex
a line segment to the midpoint of the
opposite side what do you call that
segment when you draw from the vertex to
the midpoint that's called a median and
notice we've got one two three medians
that intersect or coincide or this point
of concurrency at X is called our
centroid so what do we know about our
centroid here we've got ZR the length of
ZR is 27 what would be the length of z x
see if you can pause the video and do
that one now if I was going to do it I
know that the centroid there's that
property of what we call one-third and
two-thirds so when you draw from the
vertex to the midpoint of the opposite
side the distance from the vertex to the
centroid that's going to be the longer
portion that's the two-thirds of the
whole median the part from the centroid
to the opposite side here this is the
shorter piece that's the one-third and
usually you can tell by looking at the
diagram so if I was to take 1 3 of 20
seven that's like dividing by three this
length right here would be 9
and 2 3 is double one third so if I
double nine this segment right here is
going to be 18 and that's what z x is
and that's what we're trying to solve
for of course you can just do in one
step two-thirds times 27 but sometimes
it's easier to find the one-third
portion and then double it so that's an
important property using the centroid
now for 45 what would you do on this one
we're trying to find the length of MP
and notice we're connecting the midpoint
of these two sides of the triangle
that's called a midsegment of a triangle
do you remember how to work with the
midsegment of a triangle see if you can
do this one now if I was going to do it
what I remember about the mid segment is
that the mid segment is going to be
parallel to the base and half as long as
the base so if this is half as long as
the base if I double that length see 2
times X plus 3 that will equal the base
3x minus 4. I could also cut this in
half and set it equal to the mid segment
either way but sometimes when you do
that you get some fractions which makes
it a little bit more challenging to work
with
so now if we subtract 2x from both sides
and add 4 to both sides
solving this equation we get X is equal
to 10 and you can see if you put it back
in this would make this 26 and this
would make this 13 and that makes sense
the mid segment is half of the base
okay for number 46 see if you can do
this one how would you list the angles
from smallest to largest in this
triangle and keep in mind when you're
doing these geometry problems sometimes
the figure isn't drawn to scale and so
if I was going to do this one I would
notice that the smallest angle is across
from the shortest side so I would say
that g is the smallest
and then after that across from the
medium side would be angle e
and then the longest is a the largest
angles across from the longest side
which would be angle F so gef okay see
if you can pause the video and do number
47 it says what are the possible lengths
of the third side of the triangle with
side lengths of six centimeters and two
centimeters how would you do that
problem
well if I was going to do it the short
way of doing it is to basically subtract
these two lengths that would give you
four and add these two lengths that
would give you eight and the third side
has to be in between four and eight but
not including four or eight now if you
want to understand this a little bit
deeper why does this work well imagine
if you had a line segment that was 6 and
a line segment that was like two now if
you open up that angle like almost to
180 degrees almost like a straight line
you can see that that third side would
have to basically be the sum of those
two lengths like two and six would be
eight now the opposite extreme is if you
take that angle and you close it down
like say if this is six and then this is
like kind of like two like that now it
really only has to go from here to here
which is a six minus 2 4. so basically
when you open it up or close it from
between 180 or to zero that's kind of
what gives you the extremes here
so let's look at number 48 now now this
one
I'll just give you the instructions here
which side is longer is AC longer is d e
longer or are they equal to each other
how do you know see if you can do that
problem
now if I was going to do this this is
speaking to the hinge theorem remember
the side angle side side angle side so
if the two sides that make up the angle
are the same but the angle in between is
different than the angle that or I'm
sorry the side is across from the larger
angle is going to be the longer side so
in this case AC is going to be greater
than d e of course if the angles were
congruent and the two sides that make up
the angle are congruent then that's our
side angle side triangle congruence
theorem and then by cpctc those would
actually be equal but you just think of
a hinge you know the more you open up
that angle then the side across is going
to be longer okay for number 49 we've
got three parts here in a regular 18 God
so 18 size 18 angles are all equal the
sum of the interior angles see if you
can find that the measure of one
interior angle and the measure of one
exterior angle so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do that one the key
formula here for a is this formula here
n minus 2 times 180. so if it's an 18
gun we have 18 minus 2 which is 16 times
180 let's go to the calculator on that
one
that's giving us
2880 degrees
and if we wanted to find the measure of
just one interior angle we could
actually divide this by 18.
and let's see what that comes out to so
that's 160 degrees and if we wanted to
find the exterior angle we can either
take 180 minus 160 and get 20. that's
one way to do it or all the exterior
angles in our polygon always add up to
360. so if you take 360
divided by the 18 exterior angles that's
going to give you the measure of just
one
exterior angle so just remember when you
have a polygon let's just say this is
your polygon just kind of draw it like
that see when you extend that side
that's an exterior angle that's an
interior angle they form a linear pair
so they add up to 180. so sometimes I'll
actually try to find the exterior angle
first because that's a little easier
formula 360 divided by the number of
exterior angles to get one exterior
angle and then just subtract from 180 to
get the interior angle
so some good formulas here you might
want to write down okay it looks like
we've reached about the halfway point
we're at number 50 so there's about 100
questions or so but some of the problems
have obviously multiple parts to them so
it says given parallelogram that's what
this symbol is here w x y z find r s t u
and v in this diagram so how would you
do that one so keep in mind that it's a
parallelogram
so if I was going to do this problem
what I would notice is that in a
parallelogram the opposite angles are
congruent so that means that s here
would have to be 60 degrees
and I know that the consecutive angles
are the ones next to each other they're
supplementary they add up to 180 so I
know angle T is going to be 120 and
because the opposite angles here are
congruent R is going to be 120. okay so
we've got those and then we also know
that in a parallelogram the opposite
sides are congruent so U plus 5 equals 8
so that means that U is equal to 3
and same thing here R minus 1 is equal
to 10 so that means that R is equal to
11.
and we've got it so let's look at number
51. now this one is also a parallelogram
and
we want to find out what X and Y are in
this parallelogram so how would you do
that one
well if I was going to do it one of the
properties of parallelogram so we didn't
cover a number 50 is that the diagonals
they bisect each other they cut each
other in half so each half is equal to
the other half so we can say that 3x
minus 2 is equal to X plus seven so that
means that 2x is equal to 9 or you could
say x is equal to 4.5 and the same thing
with the Y's we could say 2y minus 5
equals y plus 5. subtract Y and add 5
and you can see that Y is equal to 10.
so let's go to number 52 now this is a
rhombus which is a special type of
parallelogram and remember neurombus
there's a lot of different properties
let's go through them real quick so in a
rhombus we know that
all the sides are congruent that's one
of the special uh characteristics of
rhombus and before I give away the other
ones see if you can figure this out the
measure of angle MCA the measure of
angle one and the measure of angle two
so if I was going to do that I would
continue on with these properties of
rhombi which is that the diagonals are
perpendicular okay so they form right
angles and so that means that angle MCA
would be a 90 degree angle or a right
angle and the other property of rambi is
that the diagonals they bisect the
opposite angle so that means if this guy
is 60 this is 60 and a ROM is a special
type of parallelogram so the opposite
angles are congruent and the diagonal
bisects the opposite angle so that means
that all four of these are going to be
60 degrees
and then you can see that when we have a
triangle here and in a triangle all the
angles add up to 90. so if this is 60
and this is 90 angle 2 has to be 30
so that's 30 degrees
okay so number 53 we're on to rectangles
now so a rectangle is a special type of
parallelogram and how would you find the
measure of angle SCA and the length of
segment CT
well in a rectangle we know that it's a
parallelogram but it has four right
angles
so that means that angle SCA is going to
be a 90 degree angle
and CT which is the length of this
diagonal we know in rectangles that the
diagonals are congruent and because it's
a special type of parallelogram that
diagonals bisect each other
so that means that this segment's four
this is for this is for this is for CT
is eight S A is eight both the diagonals
are congruent
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 54 it says given isosceles
trapezoid d-o-g-s
find the measure of angle s angle G
angle D and the length of segment OG so
how would you do that one see if you can
pause the video now the key thing here
is that it's an isosceles trapezoid what
does that mean isosceles trapezoid well
it means that the
two legs or these two sides are
congruent so that means if DS is 7 OG
also has to be 7.
and then when it's an isosceous
trapezoid what we know is that the base
angles are congruent so these two angles
are the same and these two angles are
the same so if this is 130 that means
angle o is 130 degrees
okay where did I put an angle oh I guess
I didn't put angle oh here this is
probably this is angle O Okay so that's
130. and then over here that means these
two angles see these are parallel lines
in a trapezoid and this is like a
transversal and these are what we call
consecutive interior angles so if this
is 130 this angle has to be 50
okay because they add up to 180 and that
means that this angle here also has to
be 50 because the base angles are
congruent so that means that s is 50
and this one over here G would also be
50.
okay so you got that one and now let's
go on to number 55 so it's this fine AP
and notice what's interesting about this
problem is we've got a quadrilateral and
you can see it's a trapezoid because we
have one pair of opposite sides parallel
but notice we're connecting the two
midpoints of the two legs or sides of
this trapezoid so what you want to do
here is you want to use your mid-segment
theorem so remember the mid segment
theorem it's basically an average of the
two bases these are the two parallel
sides so what we do is we'd add these
together and divide by two so I'd say X
plus 10 X plus 10 divided by 2 is equal
to the mid segment eight so it's like an
average so if I multiply both sides by 2
that comes out to X plus 10 is equal to
16 and if I subtract 10 x is equal to 6.
now a shortcut way of doing this is you
could say if I subtract 2 from 10 I get
8 and if I subtract 2 from 8 I get 6. so
we can do that same subtraction you know
because 8 is in right in the middle like
that
okay so for number 56 now we're given a
kite and notice a kite you have two
consecutive
sides that are congruent two pairs of
consecutive sides congruent and it wants
us to find the measure of angle iws this
angle right here this whole angle and
also wants to find the value of this
variable X so how would you do that one
see if you can pause the video and do
that one now one interesting thing is
that
in kites you have like this line of
symmetry if I was to draw a line
straight down the middle like this and
fold it over everything on the left here
would match with the right that's not
true for this diagonal here okay so just
this way now you can see then that this
whole angle here has to be congruent to
this angle here and we know in a
quadrilateral all the angles add up to
how much 360 right so if this is a
hundred seventy plus thirty a hundred
subtract that from 360 that's 260 divide
by two each of these angles has to be
130 degrees
and if we want to find X remember this
is a line of symmetry so if I fold this
over this piece 7 has to equal x plus 2
so if I subtract 2 x would equal 5. so
just think of that line of symmetry
now for 57 it says tell whether the
triangles are similar and if so find X
so what do you think for 57 are these
triangles similar and if they are how
would you find this segment length x
now if I was going to do it remember
there's three different ways to prove
triangles are similar there's the angle
angle similarity where you show two
angles congruent to two angles there's
the side side similarity where you show
all three sides of one triangle are in
the same ratio as all three sides of
another triangle or the side angle side
similarity where the two sides that make
up the angle are in the same ratio in
both triangles and the angle in between
is congruent now in this particular
example we can see vertical angles are
going to be congruent we've got parallel
lines which means that this angle and
this angle are congruent by alternate
interior angles
and so that means that yes these two
triangles are similar
by the angle angle similarity and I
would take it one step further and say
triangle v x u v x u is similar that's
the symbol for similar to congruent to
Triangle so v s they say v x u yeah vxu
well why did I say x sorry vtu
the TU to Triangle Str right Str okay so
now what we want to do is we want to
match up the corresponding parts now you
can see this triangle if I rotate it
like 180 degrees turn it so that the
angles match up I can see that this side
3 is going to match up with 9. so I'm
going to make a little proportion here 3
is to 9 as X is to 5.
and if we cross multiply on the diagonal
here we get 9x is equal to 15.
divide both sides by 9 and you can see X
is coming out to Five Thirds if you
reduce
okay great job if you're able to get
that one okay see if you can do number
58 it says the prisms are similar find
the surface area and volume of this
larger prism so you can see these are
like pentagonal prisms the two bases are
our pentagons and they're telling us
that the surface area and volume of this
smaller one but how do we find the
surface area and volume of this larger
one now it's not drawn to scale but you
can see they're giving us this side
length here too and this corresponding
side length eight
so how would you do that one see if you
can pause the video now if I was going
to do it see how the ratio is one to
four
but when you're comparing the surface
areas areas two-dimensional right length
and width it's like 2D you have to
square that
ratio of those two sides at similarity
ratio so that's going to be a ratio of 1
to 16. so when I go to find the surface
area I'm going to say 1 to 16 is equal
to the surface area of the smaller one
100 to X we'll say so if I cross
multiply I get X is equal to
1600 so the surface area of the larger
one is going to be 1600
centimeters squared
now when you're doing this proportion
one thing to kind of wash for is see how
I'm doing like
small to large small to large one is
smaller than 16 so I'm doing the small
figure to the large figure the surface
area the small figure the large figure
so you want to keep that consistent and
then if we're doing the volume see
volume is
three-dimensional length width and
height right 3D so if we take that
similarity ratio and Cube it one cubed
is 1 4 cubed is 64. the ratio of the
volumes is going to be 1 to 64. and so
we're going to do small to large
small too large now when we cross
multiply we get X is equal to 64 times 3
see what that is that comes out to a
volume of 19
200 centimeters cubed I didn't mark this
as centimeters but I guess it's
centimeters so 19 200 centimeters cubed
okay good so for number 59 are the
triangles here similar and how do you
know see if you can do that one
now if I was going to do this problem
here I would
see that there's three sides that
they're giving us and three sides so I
would check to see if they're similar by
the side side similarity and when you do
the side side similarity you want to
compare the short side in this triangle
to the short side in this triangle
medium to medium large longest to
longest right so you don't necessarily
want to just go
like like you're sliding one triangle
over like that because it might be a
reflection it might be a rotation Etc so
let's compare two to six that's the
short side here to short side here
that's one-third right
let's see medium to medium five to
Fifteen that's in a ratio of one to
three and the longest here to the
longest here 8 to 24 that's also one to
three so the triangles are similar and
We Know by side side similarity now if
you wanted to write your similarity
statement
you could say triangle and now watch how
I'm going to do this I'm going to do
short medium long c258 so short medium
long so that's e f g so triangle e f g
is similar to Triangle short medium long
right so i h j c i h j it makes it easy
to match them up that way okay for
number 60 now we want to solve for axis
missing side now notice we have a
triangle and we have this line segment
that's parallel to the base now this is
called the triangle proportionality
theorem in some books some books call it
the side splitting theorem how would you
solve for x in this one
well if I was going to do it I would
make a proportion I would say six is to
1.5 as X is to 2 6 is to 1.5 has access
to two pretty easy right A to B C to D
cross multiply we get 1.5 x is equal to
12 and if we divide both sides by 1.5 I
believe that's eight but let's just
double check
yes it's eight so that means X is equal
to 8.
okay see if you can pause the video and
don't do number 61. so here what you'll
notice is we have an angle bisector how
do we solve for x in this problem well
this is what's called the angle bisector
theorem so if I was going to do this
what you can do is you can actually
think of folding this top triangle onto
this bottom triangle and you can form
make a proportion that way you can say 2
is to 3
as X plus 2
is to 2x minus 1. then you can cross
multiply and solve so if we do that
we're going to get 4X minus 2
is equal to 3x Plus 6.
and if we subtract 3x we get X and if we
add 2 we get 8 and you can see X is
coming out to 8 there
so that's the angle bisector theorem I
like to do it that way just kind of fold
the triangle like this A to B C to D
okay for 62 now how would you solve for
this missing side
see if you can pause video and do that
one now this one we can see we have a
right triangle so when we have a right
triangle we can use a Pythagorean
theorem so you remember the Pythagorean
theorem from algebra a squared plus b
squared equals c squared the two legs
squared added together equal the
hypotenuse squared the one across from
the right angle but what you can also do
is you can make use of what we call
Pythagorean triples so you probably
remember three four five is a
Pythagorean triple or 5 12 13 is a
Pythagorean triple or 8 15 17 or 7 24 25
these ones are good to memorize you
might want to put these on your note
sheet or multiples of these meaning you
can multiply three four five by two and
get six eight ten that's also a right
triangle we're multiplying by a 10 30 40
50 like that
so what I do when I see a triangle like
this sometimes I say is that a
Pythagorean triple well I can divide
these both by two if I do that I'll get
7 I'll get 25 and I can see oh yeah
that's a 7 24 25 Pythagorean triple but
since I doubled 25 and doubled seven I'd
have to double 24 so that means that
this missing side is 48. so it's kind of
like a shortcut if you don't like that
method just go ahead and do Pythagorean
theorem but sometimes when you're taking
like a Time tests that can save you a
little bit of time
okay for number 63 is the triangle right
acute or obtuse given side lengths of 4
7 and 9. see if you can do that problem
how would you figure that out
well if I was going to do it I would
remember the
triangle let's see basically it's like a
variation on the Pythagorean theorem you
could say c squared is greater than a
squared plus b squared that means it's
number two triangle you could say that c
squared is less than a squared plus b
squared that means it's an acute
triangle and if c squared is equal to a
squared plus b squared that's what we're
used to that's going to be a right
triangle now the reason it works is
because if you look at a right triangle
here A B and C what happens if C gets
longer see this angle across from it is
going to get bigger right so so what we
kind of did is we took this Pythagorean
theorem here and we flipped it and put C
or the hypotenuse on the left so this
way when c squared is greater we think
of Greater like obtuse like bigger less
than it's getting smaller it's acute and
equal to its right so in this case you
want to make sure that the longest side
is your C side so we're checking is 9
squared greater than less than or equal
to 4 squared plus 7 squared so that's 81
16 plus 49
which comes out to how much that's 55.65
so you can see 81 is greater than 65
which means that we have an obtuse
triangle okay for 64 and 65 see if you
can pause the video and do these two
problems these are what we call our
special right triangles our 30 60 90 and
our 45 45 90.
now in a 30-60-90 these are the ratios
that you want to remember the one across
from the 30 degree angle we call that
side x the one across from the 60 we
call that side x root 3 and the one
across from the 90 we call that 2x so if
you kind of know these ratios it makes
it pretty simple you just say what side
are they giving me they're giving me the
2xi which is 12. how do I go from 2x to
1x oh I'm just dividing by 2. okay so 12
divided by 2 is 6. and then I say okay I
want to get to this side here which is
my X root 3 side how do I go from X to X
root 3 oh I just have to multiply this
side by square root of 3. okay so y
equals 6 square root of 3.
45 45 90 we're able to get this one
well it looks like they're giving us
these three sides here and remember in a
45 45 90 the two legs we call these like
x x and the hypotenuse x times the
square root of 2. so it's pretty easy if
you know these three quantities you say
well if I'm given the X root 2 side 8
how do I go back to the x side well I
have to get rid of the square root of 2
by dividing by square root of 2. same
thing over here so you're dividing by
square root of 2. so X and Y are
actually congruent it's an isosceles
triangle so what is 8 divided by the
square root of 2. well we can
rationalize by multiplying the top and
bottom by square root of 2 square root
of 2 times square root of 2 square root
of 4 which is 2 and 8 divided by 2 comes
out to four so this is 4 square root of
2 for both X and Y
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 66 it says find the geometric
mean of 9 and 16. so what does that mean
the geometric mean there's a couple
different ways you can do this one way
to do it is you can set up a proportion
where you put 9
and 16 here and you put X here these are
called the the means and these are
called the extremes we're solving for
the mean and then what you can do is you
can cross multiply x squared equals 9
times 16 which is 144.
and then you take the square root of
both sides you can see your geometric
mean is equal to 12. now that's one way
to do it it's to set up as a proportion
the other way to do it is you can just
memorize the geometric mean is the
square root of a times B so these are
your two numbers you just multiply them
and take the square root so either way
number 67 now we're given a right
triangle and we've dropped an altitude
and so we have this little triangle
medium triangle and the overall triangle
what we're trying to solve for x and y
so see if you can pause the video and do
that problem
now sometimes this problem is only
covered like an honors geometry or you
know Advanced geometry but I'll just
show you here how you would do this the
altitude acts is the geometric mean of
the two parts of the hypotenuse that
it's splitting it up into so what we can
say is that uh 4 is equal to
like this so basically you've got your
geometric mean X it's a geometric mean
of four and nine so when you cross
multiply you can see you're getting x
squared equals 36.
take this square root so X is coming out
to 6 so that's the altitude here the
height now if you want to solve for y
the leg there's a leg geometric mean
theorem where you say that the leg
is the geometric mean of the hypotenuse
which is 13 and the part of the
hypotenuse is adjacent to that leg so
now when you cross multiply you get y
squared is equal to 52 and if you take
the square root square root of 52 is
like 4 square root of 4 times square
root of 13 so it'd be like 2 square root
of 13. that's an exact answer
so just remember the altitude I find is
a little bit easier the altitude is the
geometric mean of the two parts that it
splits it up into and then the leg is
the geometric mean of the whole
hypotenuse and the part of the
hypotenuse adjacent to that leg
okay for number 68 now we're getting
into some trigonometry can you find the
sine of angle a cosine of angle a and
tangent of angle a in this triangle how
would you do that one now if I was going
to do it I would reference that acronym
remember this so
acronym so what does that stand for the
sine is the ratio of the opposite side
divided by the hypotenuse the cosine is
the ratio of the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse and the tangent is the ratio
of the opposite side over the adjacent
side so socatoa so sine I would position
myself here at angle a the sine is the
opposite side 8 over the hypotenuse
which is 17. that's the side across from
the right angle the cosine of angle a
would be the adjacent side now adjacent
means next to but not the hypotenuse
right so 15 over 17 so adjacent over
hypotenuse tangent of angle a opposite
over adjacent so that would be 8 over
15.
okay number 69 and number 70. see if you
can pause the video and do these two
problems here we're solving for the
missing side here we're solving for the
missing angle
what you want to do if I was going to do
this problem here is I position myself
at the angle and I'd say which one of
these trig functions sine cosine or
tangent ties together the opposite side
and the hypotenuse that's our sign so I
would say the sine of 12 degrees is
equal to opposite over hypotenuse then
I'd multiply both sides by 16
and let's go to the calculator make sure
you're in degrees sometimes people
comment they say oh I got a different
answer and that's because they're in
radians or like that so make sure you're
in the right mode and so now we've got
16 sine of 12. so that comes out to uh
3.33 okay approximately and then number
70 what trig function ties together
opposite and adjacent well that's
tangent right see opposite adjacent
tangent but when you're solving for the
angle what you want to do is you want to
do the inverse trig function so the
tangent inverse of opposite over
adjacent when you know the angle use the
regular sine cosine tangent when you're
solving for the angle use the inverse so
you might have to press the second key
on your calculator
and so I'm getting about
33 point seven degrees I'll just round a
little bit so 33.7 okay see if you can
pause the video and do number 71 72 and
73. so for 71 we're given this triangle
we've got two angles and we've got this
side and we're trying to solve for this
side here so how would you do that one
now notice that it's not a right
triangle so we can't really use our sine
cosine tangent like our sohcahtoa right
triangle trigonometry but we can use our
Law of Sines because it's not a right
triangle so if I was going to do this
problem I would think of the angle and
the side across from that angle as a
pair angle on the side across as a pair
so what I mean by that is I'm going to
say sine of 40 degrees over its side
opposite is equal to the sine of 100
degrees over its side opposite and then
all you have to do is cross multiply so
we get x times the sine of 40 degrees is
equal to 10 times the sine of 100
divide both sides by sine of 40 to get X
by itself
and let's go ahead and put that in the
calculator now while I'm doing that you
might want to look at this formula here
you might want to add this to your
formula sheet
notice It's The Sign of the angle over
the side opposite sign anything over the
side opposite sign anything over the
side opposite you only need to use two
of these three ratios to make a
proportion and then cross multiply some
books they actually have at the reverse
where they have side a over sine a side
B over sine b side C over sine C it's
the same thing you'll get the same
result so again make sure you're in
degrees
okay and let's see what we're getting so
for this one did you get 15.3
approximately
approximately 15.3 okay so for 72 now
let's take a look at this one so how did
you do this one we've got uh this
triangle here and we're trying to solve
for side C now notice they're giving us
a side angle side when they give you
side angle side and that's it or they
give you side side like three sides
that's when you have to use the law of
cosines and I've written the three
different forms of the law of cosines
down here you might want to add those to
your formula sheet so it looks like here
because I'm solving for side C I would
use this top formula and so it's going
to be side C squared is equal to a
squared which is 6 squared plus b
squared that's 8 squared minus 2 times 6
times 8 times the cosine of 120 degrees
now this is c squared so I'm going to
have to take the square root of this
whole thing and let me go ahead and do
that on the calculator so we've got 6
squared is 36 plus 64 minus 2 times 6
times 8 times the cosine of 120
and then I'm going to take the square
root of that answer
so I'm getting approximately
12.17
so that's the side right here okay for
number 73 now we're going to find the
area of this triangle now notice it's
not like our normal one-half base times
height we don't know the height so one
way to do this problem is
to use one of these formulas you
probably learned this where you do side
one times side two times the sine of the
angle in between times a half so you can
use that formula or what I like to do
sometimes is just drop an altitude like
this so I can make that into a right
angle and I can say hmm this is my
height sine of 83 equals opposite over
hypotenuse right so sine of 83 equals H
over 10 multiply both sides by 10. and
what is the 10 times the sine of 83 it's
about
9.93 so we'll write that down 9.93 so
now we know the area of a triangle is
one half base times height so the base
is this bottom portion here 12. our
height we said was about 9.93
and if we multiply that together what do
we get so 0.5 times 6 times 12 times
9.93 okay so it looks like it's about
approximately
59.6 I'll just round a little bit here
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 74 75 and 76. so 74 we're
given this diagram here and we want to
label a chord A secant a tangent a point
of tangency a common internal tangent
and the measure of angle one we want to
find so how would you do that problem
well if I was going to do it let's see a
chord is basically a line segment with
two endpoints on the circle so I would
say this is segment FC and be careful
you put that little bar to indicate that
it's a a segment and not like a line or
a rate and then secant is a line that
intersects The Circle at two points so
here I would say f g line FG is a secant
tangent it just touches a circle at one
point so for example I could say
let's just say for example this here
would be a tangent like line CE
and what's interesting about this one
this is actually what we call a common
external tangent so it doesn't if you
connect the two centers of the two
circles it doesn't cross through that
line connecting the two centers so they
call that on the outside or an external
and it's a common in common to both
circles
now a point of tangency could be just
like Point C that's where it just the
tangent line just barely touches the
circle and a common internal tangent see
this one here it's tangent to both
circles but it's going in between
or uh you know the circles basically
it's going through that Center Line that
connects the two centers of the circles
so I would say that that's line G D
and then measure of angle one when you
draw a radius to the point of tangency
this is always going to be a right angle
a 90 degree angle so I'm going to say 90
degrees for that one
okay for number 75 now how would you
find the value of x notice we have a two
tangents to this circle here one kind of
going above the circle one kind of going
below the circle what's the connection
here between these two tangents well
both of these tangents are equal to one
another so all we have to do is set them
equal and solve so this is going to come
out to let's see subtract 3 2x from both
sides add 1 to both sides so it looks
like x equals six we can check our work
that's going to be 17 17 okay for 76 now
we're given this diagram here and it
says is Arc RT
a major arc a minor Arc or a semi-circle
okay and then what is the measure of Arc
RT
okay so now what's interesting is in a
circle all these arcs the measures of
all these arcs have to add up to 360
degrees right so if we have 90 100 140
we can solve for this missing
uh central angle right there and the way
we can do that let's see that's 240
which would then be 330
so this would be 30. now if the central
angle is 30 then the measure of this Arc
is also 30 so we have 90 plus 30 is 120
so that's going to be the measure of Arc
RT and when you're less than 180
we know that it's going to be a minor
Arc if it's exactly 180 we know it's a
semi-circle in which case you'd have to
use three points on the circle and major
arc is more than 180 and again you have
to use three points so just the way
that's written you can kind of tell that
it's a minor Arc
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 77 so here we have a circle
and we've got uh two chords so how would
you find what x is in this diagram well
if I was going to do it what I notice is
that these two chords they're
equidistant from the center and you see
how these are both three so when the
chords are equidistant from the center
that means that they're the same length
so all I have to do is set 3x minus 7.
equal to X plus 18 and solve so if we
subtract X that's 2x if we add 7 that's
25 and if we divide both sides by 2 x is
12.5
okay for number 78 now we've got this
diagram we want to find the measure of
angle one we want to find out whether
measure of angle 2 and angle one are
equal to each other or if one is greater
or if 2 is greater and then the measure
of angle 3 this is not at the center the
center is somewhere over here so how
would you solve this problem
well notice that measure of angle 1 that
vertex that hinge is right on the circle
so when the vertex is on the circle we
call that an inscribed angle and this
inscribed angle is half of the
intercepted Arc The Arc that's cut off
so half of 100 is going to be 50 degrees
now notice angle 2 is also an inscribed
angle and notice it's intercepting the
exact same Arc of 100 degrees sometimes
they don't even give you this uh
Arc measure but they'll just say which
one's bigger one or two and but you have
to kind of realize they're intercepting
the same Arc so that the two angles are
actually going to be equal to each other
and then for angle three when you have a
circle and you have two chords that like
intersect but not necessarily at the
center when you want to find that that
angle what you do is you average the two
intercepted arcs so you would add the
two arcs together and divide by two so I
would say 60 plus 100 is 160 divided by
2 angle 3 would be 80. so it's like an
average of those two arcs now if you
wanted to find this angle you could then
subtract from 180 since these form a
linear pair
okay first number 79 how would you do
this one you have an inscribed
quadrilateral inside a circle how would
you find X and Y go ahead and pause the
video see if we can do that one
if I was going to do it I would
recognize that Y is going to be 40
degrees
and X is going to be 95 degrees because
when you inscribe a quadrilateral the
opposite angles are supplementary they
add up to 180 so that's a good theorem
to remember
now for number 80 how do you find the
measure of this Arc a b and how do you
find the measure of angle CEF okay a lot
going on in that diagram see if you can
figure that one out well if I was going
to find the measure of Arc a b
what I would recognize here is that we
have
kind of like two secant lines here and
see how it intercepts this Arc of a
hundred and let's just call this Arc
here x and then this angle on the
outside is 20. so when the angle is on
the outside of the circle like that what
we do is we take the larger Arc minus
the smaller Arc
divided by 2 and that equals this angle
on the outside 20. so if I multiply both
sides by 2
100 minus X is equal to 40 and so I can
see that X must be 60. so this is a 60
degree Arc right there
now measure of angle CEF notice that the
vertex here of this angle CEF is on the
circle when it's on the circle what you
do is you take half of the intercepted
Arc so if this is 140 angle CEF would be
70 degrees so you want to pay attention
is the vertex on the circle like this
where it's half of the intercepted Arc
is it inside like this one see how it
was inside it was like the average of
the two arcs or is it on the outside you
subtract the two arcs and divide by two
okay see if you can pause the video and
do 81 through 84. here we're solving for
measure of angle a how would you do that
one well notice you have uh two tangents
one above one below and we know the arcs
in a circle all add up to 360. that
means that this Arc here must be 160.
notice again that this angle is on the
outside of the circle we did a problem
like this previously right so how would
you solve for angle a well you would
take the larger Arc 200 minus the
smaller Arc 160 and divide by 2 and
that's going to be the measure of angle
a so that's 40. divided by 2 which is
20. so 20 degrees
okay for number 82 now how would you do
this one you have two intersecting
chords
and they're not really Crossing at the
center of the circle so how would you
solve for x on that one
well if I was doing this problem it's
pretty easy just take the two parts of
the chord and you multiply them together
you say 5 times 8 is equal to 4 times x
so that comes out to 40 is equal to 4X
divide both sides by 4 x is equal to 10.
and for 83 now we have a tangent and a
secant how do you find the length of
that tangent go ahead and try that one
on your own
this one what you do is you take the
whole secant length which is 12.
times the part outside the circle 5
equals the tangent squared so this comes
out to 60 is equal to x squared and if
we take the square root of both sides 60
is like 4 times 15 so this is 2 square
root of 15. that's like an exact answer
you can get a decimal if you want on
that one
okay for number 84 we have two secants
we have this one and this one so how do
we find X in this problem go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do that
one
well when it's two secants you take the
whole secant length 16 times the part
outside the circle 6 and that equals
this whole secant length which is X plus
four times the part outside which is X
so just think whole times external
equals the whole times the external
that's how I remember it so this comes
out to 96 is equal to x squared plus 4X
let's subtract 96 from both sides of
this equation set it to zero and let's
see if we can Factor this
so what multiplies to negative 96 but
adds to 4
well that would be
um 12 and 8 right so this would be X
plus 12 and x minus 8. now if we set
both of these factors equal to zero
if we subtract 12 from both sides we get
x equals negative 12. we really can't
have a negative length so that's
extraneous if we add 8 to both sides we
get x equals eight yeah that that works
okay so we're moving on to some circle
problem let's see if you can do number
85 86 and 87. go ahead and pause the
video for 85 write the equation of this
circle drawn here so how would you do
that well the first thing we want to do
is kind of review what is the standard
form of the equation of a circle well
it's this x minus H squared plus y minus
K squared is equal to the radius squared
so you might want to add this to your to
your formula sheet h k is the center
and R is the radius
okay and then you want to make sure that
see when you see the formula here that
it's x minus that x coordinate and Y
minus that y coordinate so in this case
since our Center here is at 1 2 we're
going to say x minus 1 the quantity
squared plus y minus 2 the quantity
squared is equal to the radius which you
can see is 2 squared which is 4 and you
got it so for number 86 now they're
giving us this equation of a circle
what's the center and the radius well
you can see there's not a number grouped
with the X so that means the x
coordinate would be zero this one is
going to be positive 2
. remember the number that's grouped
with this is going to have the opposite
sign because it's y minus or x minus so
if this is y plus 2 this would be
negative 2 since this is y minus 2 would
be positive 2. and then here this is the
radius squared so we have to take this
square root to get the radius so the
radius is equal to 4.
and for 87 now how would you find the
length of this
Arc a b and how would you find the area
of this shaded sector go ahead and pause
the video see if you can do that one
if I was going to do this I would make a
proportion I would say 120 degrees
is to the whole circle 360.
as this Arc Length I'll just call X is
to the entire circumference which is 2
pi times the radius so what you're doing
is you're doing the part to the whole
equals a part to the whole so the angle
is to 360 as the arc length is to the
whole circumference
we can reduce 120 over 360 to 1 3
that'll make a little bit easier so now
when we cross multiply we get 3x equals
6 pi and if we divide whoops 6 Pi I
meant if we divide by 3 you can see X is
equal to 2 pi centimeters and that's an
exact answer for the length of that
curved portion there and for Part B how
do we find the area of the Shaded sector
well kind of the same idea you would do
120 over 360 part to the whole equals
the area of the sector I'll just call X
through the area of the whole circle
area of a circle is pi r squared
so now again we can reduce this is like
one third
Again part to the whole equals the area
of the sector to the whole area of the
whole circle part to whole part to whole
cross multiply this is nine pi times one
and x times 3 is 3x and if we divide
both sides by 3 you can see X is coming
out to 3 pi
centimeters squared and that's like an
exact answer for the area of this sector
see if you can pause the video and do
number 88 we're trying to find the area
of this kite how would you find the area
of the kite well the key thing is to
know the area of a kite formula which is
uh one half diagonal one times diagonal
two so diagonal one times diagonal two
now remember this is a line of symmetry
so if we fold it over that line of
symmetry that means this will also be
five so that means we have one half
diagonal one which is 10 times diagonal
2 which is 14 and that comes out to half
of 140 which is 70 units squared for 89
how do you find the area of this regular
hexagon see if you can pause the video
and do this one well there's a couple
different ways to do it you could use
the area equals one half a possum times
perimeter formula or you can divide this
into triangles and find the area of one
of the triangles and then multiply by 6
since you have six triangles in a circle
that's 360 Degrees if I divide it by 6 I
get a central angle here of 60 and if I
drop an altitude what happens is it
bisects the base and it bisects this
angle so what we get is a 30 60 90
triangle
and so you can see if this is 5 this
must be 5 square root of 3. so that's
knowing your special rate triangles x x
root 3 and 2x so if we wanted to find
the area of this Triangle Well actually
let's use this formula here first so
we'll do one half the apothem which is 5
root 3 that's the height of the triangle
the altitude of the triangle times the
perimeter which is 10 times 6 that's 60
that's going to give us 150
square root of 3
centimeters squared so that would be
your exact answer for your area now if
you wanted to find just the area of this
triangle you could do one half the base
which is 10
times the height which we said was 5
root 3
and then multiply by six triangles
that's another way you would still get
150 square root of 3.
now for number 90 and 91 we want to find
the surface area and then we want to
find the volume
of this triangular prism so how would
you do that one go ahead and pause the
video there the key here is to know the
formula so the formula of a surface area
is what it's the area of the base times
two since we have a top and a bottom
plus the perimeter of the base
times the height so I'll make a little
room here so the area of the base is a
triangle so that's going to be one half
base times height so 3 times 4 which is
12.
okay and then plus the perimeter now
notice this is a three four five
Pythagorean triple okay so that comes
out to a perimeter of 12 times the
height which is the distance between the
two triangular bases that's 10. so we
get 2 times a half is 1 times 12 is 12
plus 120 gives us 132 units squared for
our surface area now for the volume the
volume it's an easier formula it's the
area of the base times the height the
base we said was a triangle so that's
one half base times height so half of 12
is 6 and the height is 10 so that's
going to give us 60 units cubed and
that's your volume
now for 92 and 93 a little bit different
we're given a cylinder and they give us
the volume but we want to find the
radius and then once we do that then we
want to find the surface area of this
cylinder so see we can pause the video
and do that one
now if I was going to do it I know the
volume of a cylinder it's a kind of like
a circular prism it's the area of the
base times the height so we've got 432
pi equals the area of the base which is
a circle that's pi r squared times the
height which they tell us is 12. so if I
divide both sides by 12 pi
that gives me r squared by itself so
let's go to the calculator what's 432 pi
divided by 12 Pi that's 36 so we have r
squared is equal to 36 take the square
root of both sides and you can see the
radius is coming out to 6 inches
so now if we want to find the surface
area we're going to do the area of the
base times two since we have a top and a
bottom plus the perimeter of the base
times the height now the area of the
base is a circle so we could say 2 times
pi r squared the perimeter of the base
is a circle so that's like our
circumference right so that's 2 pi r
times our height so let's put in
everything we know so 2 pi times 6
squared plus 2 pi times 6 times 12. if
we simplify that down we get 36 times 2
is 72 pi
plus let's see 2 times 6 is 12 times 12
is 144 pi and 72 plus 144 is
216 Pi inches
squared and now you've got the surface
area
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 94 95 96 and 97 surface area
and volume of a pyramid and a cone so
let's look at the pyramid here first so
we want to find the volume so the volume
we can use the Formula 1 3 area of the
base times the height now the base you
can see this is a square all the sides
are congruent it's a square pyramid so
this is going to be area of the base is
10 times 10 so that's a hundred
and the height that's this perpendicular
distance here which is 12. so if we
multiply that together we get 1 3 of 12
is 4 times 100 would be 400 units cubed
that's our volume now for the surface
area what we have to do is we have to
use the formula area of the base
plus one half the perimeter of the base
times the slant height now we don't have
the slant height here but we can draw it
in let me see if I can draw this right
here
okay now notice that this forms a
triangle and if this is 10 for the side
length that means this is 5 and notice
we have a 5 12 13
Pythagorean triple you could also do the
Pythagorean theorem so now we've got the
area of the base which is 10 times 10
that's a hundred
plus one half the perimeter of the base
that's going to be 40. and then the
slant height is 13. so let's see half of
40 is 20. 20 times 13 is 260 plus the
100 that's coming out to 360 units
squared is our surface area okay now for
the cone we want to find the volume in
the surface area the volume of a cone
it's the same formula as the volume for
a pyramid it's one-third the area of the
base times the height it's just that the
base is a circle so we're going to use
the formula pi r squared for the base
times the height so let's go ahead and
do that so we've got the radius is 3 3
squared is 9. the height is 4
. so if we multiply that together we get
a third of nine is three times four is
twelve so we're getting 12 Pi units
cubed for our volume
and then for our surface area we can use
the same formula for the pyramid base
plus one half the perimeter of the base
times the slant height now the base is a
circle so that's going to be pi r
squared
and the perimeter is the circumference
so that's going to be 2 pi r and then
the slant height now again we don't know
the slant height but we can see it's a
three four five Pythagorean triple you
could also do the Pythagorean theorem
and one half times two that comes out to
one so this formula simplifies a little
bit down so it's pi times 3 squared plus
pi times
3 times the slant height of 5. so if we
do that we get 9 pi
okay plus 15 pi
which is equal to 24 pi
uh units squared since its area so I
kind of did it going up instead of down
all right so let's take a look at a few
more problems okay before we do these
last three problems great job if you
were able to make it through all of
these uh problems uh leave a comment if
you don't mind just kind of let me know
if you did go through this whole
geometry final exam review and how you
did and if you want more help like I
said I'll put a link at the end of this
video here to uh another geometry final
exam review that I did a few years ago
I'll put some links in the description
also you can check out my geometry
course on my YouTube channel it's called
complete chorus geometry complete course
something of that nature and it goes
into more depth kind of explaining the
whys and the hows of how to solve some
of these problems so check that out if
you're stuck on any of these Concepts
but let's finish up number 98.99 the
surface area and volume of this sphere
the formula you want to know for surface
area is the 4 pi r squared so in a
sphere the only the important Dimension
really is that radius right so the
distance from the center of the sphere
to a point on the sphere and that's
going to be 4 pi times 5 squared 5
squared is 25.
4 times 25 is a hundred so we get a
hundred Pi centimeters squared is our
surface area the outer surface the
volume the formula you want to memorize
or add your formula sheet is this four
thirds pi R cubed and sometimes people
get confused which one goes with which
just remember squared is like two
dimensional and Cubed is like three
dimensional and so here we're just going
to do four thirds times pi times 5 cubed
the radius cubed 5 cubed is 125.
and if we multiply this together you can
make these fractions by putting them
over one this is going to come out to
500 pi over 3
centimeters cubed since its volume and
you can get a decimal for both of these
but I'm just leaving Pi in there to get
an exact answer and then the last
question the surface area of this
hemisphere see it's like a sphere that's
been like cut in half what's interesting
about this one is you have half of a
sphere right half of 4 pi r squared
which would be 2 pi r squared but what's
happening is now you can see the this
circle at the bottom when you when you
cut it in half so that adds another pi r
squared for this base so the surface
area of a hemisphere you want to know
this Formula 3 pi r squared so that's
going to be 3 pi times 4 squared 4
squared is 16 times 3 is 48 Pi inches
squared and that's an exact answer and
you got it so great job I want to wish
you a lot of success in your geometry
and go ahead and follow me to that video
over there if you want to get some
additional practice and I'll see you in
my future videos I'll talk to you soon